29 avril 1945 l'armée rouge s'est frayée
un passage jusqu'au coeur de berlin le
führer est retranché avec ses proches
collaborateurs dans son bunker sous la
chancellerie du reich sans plus aucun
espoir
adolf hitler prend alors une décision
inattendue il épouse eva braun sa
maîtresse depuis 14 ans l' influence
d'eva braun sur le gouvernement nazi et
sa politique
plus pratiquement nul elle a malgré tout
laissé un témoignage extraordinaire un
document filmé de ses années passées
auprès d'hitler et de son entourage
a17 au eva braun commence à travailler
en tant qu'assistante photographe au
berghof le nid d'aigle d'hitler dans les
alpes bavaroises
elle ne se sépare parce que jamais de sa
caméra le résultat est un témoignage
extraordinaire sur la vie des dirigeants
nazis
non
où
même dans le cadre informel du berghof
la relation entre adolf hitler et eva
braun n'ai connu que d'une minorité de
personnes un journaliste qui a fait
preuve de trop de curiosité sur le sujet
s'est vite retrouvé internés dans le
camp de concentration de dachau
heatley rencontre eva braun en octobre
1929 à munich dans le magasin de photos
où il travaille
le propriétaire des lieux
heinrich hoffmann que l'on voit parler
ici avec hitler et le photographe
officiel du parti nazi
quelques mois après leur première
rencontre
adolphe et va se croiser à nouveau dans
la résidence munichoise de hoffman avant
la fin de l'année 1931 elle est devenue
la maîtresse du ter elle a 19 ans 23 ans
de moins que lui
pendant plusieurs années eva braun sera
autorisé à voyager en compagnie de
hitler et a résidé pendant de longues
périodes au berghof avec la libye d'être
toujours considéré comme l'assistante
d'hoffmann
eva braun a tourné son film
principalement au berghof et dans ses
environs entre 1939 et 1944
c'est en 1929 que hitler commence à
repérer les environs de l'aubette
salzberg la montagne de la femme sacrée
dans la haute bavière
berne chez skadden la ville voisine à
une population de seulement 3500
habitants
c'est l'endroit idéal pour s'isoler des
turbulences du monde politique bavarois
en 1925 hitler loue une maison sur les
pentes de l'aubette salsberg j'ai juste
au dessus du village de berchtesgaden
ils achètent cette propriété en 1928
puis quand il est nommé chancelier en
1933 behçet gadenne devient le centre de
la scène politique allemande
celui qui est chargé de transformer le
modeste refuge d'hitler dans les
montagnes en un vaste domaine et luxueux
et martin bormann
bormann que l'on voit ici en compagnie
de hitler restera pratiquement un
inconnu pour les allemands ils fuient
des médias et se laisse rarement filmer
ou photographier martin bormann s'est
hissé au pouvoir en tant que collecteur
de fonds pour le parti
puis il a pris en charge la gestion des
finances personnelles des clercs au
départ la propriété du berghof se limite
à quelques bois entourant la maison puis
baumann commence à acquérir les terres
avoisinantes
finalement le domaine du berghof
couvrira une surface de presque 10
kilomètres carrés et une centaine
d'hectares de terres cultivables pour
financer ce projet bormann utilise les
revenus générés par les droits d'auteur
sur la vente du livre d'hitler mein
kampf il les millions de marks versées
par les membres de la haute société aux
fonds spéciaux d'hitler cependant hitler
souhaite officiellement garder une
certaine distance par rapport aux biens
matériels
il est donc décidé que la propriété du
domaine serait au nom de boorman ce qui
convient parfaitement à la nature cupide
de ce dernier la volonté de boorman de
satisfaire les désirs de hitler est sans
limite
en 1938 par exemple hitler se plaint car
la présence d'un chalet en contrebas du
berghof gâche la vue bormann dépenses
une grosse somme d'argent pour faire
disparaître ce chalet et le lendemain la
maison est démolie et de sites aménagés
la présence de hitler au berghof pendant
de longues périodes implique de plus en
plus de réunions et de conférences se
déroulent sur le demain plutôt qu'à
munich ou à berlin par conséquent la
chancellerie ouvre une annexe sur le
domaine haut construit des casernes pour
accueillir les ss et les gardes du corps
du service de sécurité pour les invités
supplémentaires un hôtel confortable et
construit dans les environs le berghof
est en effet devenu le deuxième siège du
gouvernement
la maison est agrandie en 1935 elle
comporte désormais trois étages et
compte une trentaine de pièces
hitler a lui même dessiné les plans
l'élément principal de la salle de
conférence est une immense fenêtre qui
peut descendre dans le sol au deuxième
étage
hitler à son salon sa chambre et un
bureau tout près on trouve une suite
réservée exclusivement à eva braun à
partir de 1936 elle vit quasiment en
permanence dans cette demeure
délaissant pour quelques instants son
travail de cinéaste amateur
eva braun est à son tour sous l'oeil de
la caméra en compagnie de margaret h
pire dans la vallée au pied du berghof
margarita et la femme d'albert speer
architectes et depuis 1942 ministre de
l'armement du reich
et riche gamme k le chauffeur de hitler
a décrit eva braun comme étant la femme
la plus malheureuse en allemagne depuis
le début de sa liaison avec hitler elle
est obligée de passer la plupart de ses
journées à attendre son statut ambigu
aux yeux des membres éminents du parti
nazi et de leurs épouses est pour elle
une source constante d'embarras elle a
toujours détesté ce qu'elle qualifie
comme son existence clandestine
hitler a compris qu'il serait impossible
pour lui de dissimuler très longtemps sa
liaison avec eva braun car elle vit dans
un immeuble de munich
il décide donc en 1935 de l'installer
dans une maison bourgeoise de la
banlieue munichoise
eva a déjà tenté de se suicider à deux
reprises incapable de supporter sa vie
d'isolement et de secrets puis pour la
première fois elle est enfin heureuse
elle est libre d'aller et venir comme
elle l'entend et pense ne plus rien
avoir à craindre des nombreuses
admiratrices d'hitler eva a une foi
inébranlable en est claire même
lorsqu'elle entend parler de la
sanglante purge de la nuit des longs
couteaux au cours de laquelle des
centaines d'opposants s à ont été
assassinés sous les ordres de hitler
elle ne change pas d'opinion
les parents des vases sont catholiques
et très strictes lorsqu'il découvre la
liaison entre hitler et leur fille ils
sont furieux
mais ils n'essaient pas de briser cette
relation car ils craignent de perdre
leur fille
dans sa villa eva film ses soeurs
hillside gretl ainsi que sa mère francis
quart
hitler est tellement certain que sa
liaison avec eva braun est inconnu de
tout ce qu'elle peut avec ses soeurs et
ses amis partir pour une balade
dominicale à bicyclette sont visiblement
aucun service de sécurité pour les
protéger
quand elle était toute jeune eva braun
avait été décrite par l'un de ses
professeurs comme une enfant
intelligente mais trop dissipés en
classe
elle s'intéressait en fait plus au sport
qu'à ses études et elle pratiquer la
natation la danse et le patin à glace à
l'âge de 16 ans ses parents décident de
l'envoyer finir ses études dans un
couvent en espérant que cette éducation
permettrait de dompter leur fille
frivole et incontrôlable elle est
envoyée dans la petite ville de simba re
ou des religieuses britannique dirige
une école pour jeunes filles
zim barre était situé en face de la
ville de brax ono en autriche séparés
seulement par la rivière in en 1928 bras
ono commence à devenir célèbre en tant
que ville natale d'adolphe hitler
vous
sur ces images hitler et au berghof il
porte l'uniforme brin du parti nazi
ce qui semble indiquer que ce film a été
tourné avant septembre 1939 après
l'invasion de la pologne et le début de
la guerre il prendra l'habitude de
porter l'uniforme pour toutes les
occasions officielles
un signe de son statut en tant que
commandant en chef des forces armées
allemandes
le 17 juin 1939 l'un des nombreux
étrangers en visite au berghof et filmé
alors qu'il est accueilli par les
proches de hitler c'est l'envoyé du roi
d'arabie saoudite
le conseiller royal khalid al hout il
est accompagné par le traducteur en chef
du ministère des affaires étrangères
paul schmitt derrier adjudant-chef
wilhem brookner
en 1939 eva est devenu le test non
officielle lors des réceptions donné par
hitler au berghof tout le monde sait qu
eva braun et martin bormann se déteste
profondément mais les hostilités entre
eux ne dégénère ont jamais en un réel
conflit
d'ailleurs eva sera l'une des seules
personnes contre qui boorman ne
complétera jamais adolf hitler qui peut
être très cordiales avec les gens qu'il
apprécie le plus tels que hoffman le
photographe même boorman est également
capable de rentrer dans des colères
noires qui peuvent être funeste pour la
personne qui l'a provoquée
le 12 juin 1939 eva braun film éclaire
et son escorte
lors d'une visite dans une petite école
primaire qui presque devenu un lieu de
pèlerinage du national socialisme
c'est dans cette école située dans le
village de fiches l'âme près de lembach
qu entre 1895 et 1897
adolf hitler a commencé sa scolarité on
voit ici martin bormann dans son
uniforme brin du parti nazi quittant
l'école aux côtés de hitler en 1939
bormann et le deuxième adjoint d'hitler
après rudolf hess boorman a déjà prouvé
sa dévorante ambitions pour lui seul
l'exercice du pouvoir compte lorsqu en
1941 s s'envolent ce traitement pour la
grande bretagne
martin bormann lui succède comme chef de
la chancellerie du parti il occupe une
position qui lui confère un pouvoir
considérable
bormann contrôle ainsi une grande partie
du reich et il est également le
secrétaire particulier de hitler en 1945
bormann c'est un les circonstances de sa
mort sont toujours entourées de mystère
son corps n'aurait jamais été
formellement identifiés aujourd'hui il a
été condamné par contumace au procès de
nuremberg
le 12 juillet 1939 adolf hitler entame
un nouveau voyage empreint de nostalgie
cette fois ci il se rend sur une ferme
de trois hectares dans le village d'à
feld c'est la ferme où son père
douaniers de profession avait pris sa
retraite avec le reste de la famille au
cours du printemps en 1895
chaque fois qu eva braun revient à
munich après un séjour au berghof et
l'utilisent sa caméra pour filmer les
membres de sa famille des liens très
étroits la tâche à sa famille mais sa
dévotion pour hitler lors est bien
supérieur en 1944 sa soeur gretl épouse
herman fait de line officier de liaison
de la waffen ss de hitler fait que line
sera exécutée à la fin de la guerre à
l'instigation de boorman et sur les
ordres de hitler il aurait été surpris
en train de tenter de s'échapper du bon
coeur de la chancellerie
eva braun n'intercepte pas en faveur de
son beau frère
à cette époque elle est tellement dévoué
à hitler qu'à ses yeux la traîtrise est
impardonnable
elle affirme même qu'il vaut mieux que
dix mille personnes meurent plus tôt que
l'allemagne père d'hitler
6 juillet 1940 eva braun film depuis une
fenêtre de l'ancienne chancellerie à
berlin
le cortège de véhicules du führer est
attendu d'un moment à l'autre
hitler revient dans la capitale
allemande pour la première fois après
avoir mené la guerre éclair en europe de
l'ouest
lors de cette réception
evans ne peut pas s'approcher davantage
elle doit rester dans les étages ce qui
lui permet de dominer la ville ème place
et
la conquête de la france et des pays-bas
conforte hitler dans son idée de ce que
doit être la destinée de la grande
allemagne à l'image ouvrez hitler qui
discutent de développement avec herman
et soeurs et soeurs qui est sur la
droite et est le co fondateur du parti
ouvrier allemand qui deviendra par la
suite le parti national socialiste
il fut le premier homme a publiquement
appelé adolf hitler le führer
hitler n'a aucun doute sur sa propre
destinée
il croit qu'il a été envoyé sur terre
par dieu afin de mener la nation
allemande jusqu'à la grandeur suprême sa
confiance en lui et en son propre
jugement n'a jamais été plus grande
hitler a clairement explicité à quel
point il a foi en lui il déclare je vais
dans la direction que madic la divine
providence avec l'assurance d'un
somnambule l'arrogance et l'égocentrisme
de hitler transparaissait dans sa vision
de sa relation avec eva braun
il déclare c'est un fait que les femmes
aiment les vrais hommes c'est leur
instinct qui leur conseille de chercher
la protection d'un héros
de son côté eva braun a depuis longtemps
juré qu'elle suivrait éclair en prison
en déportation et jusqu'à la mort elle
tiendra sa promesse
pendant plusieurs années hitler a
projeté de serre ériger une série de
bâtiments et de monuments grandioses à
la gloire du reich pour lui berlin doit
être au coeur de l'europe une capitale
qui représenta pour le monde
l'unique capitale ici on voit heatley a
discuté avec le créateur et sculpteur
arno breker qui était autrefois un
artiste de réputation internationale
mais son ambition l'a poussé à se
spécialiser dans des représentations
gigantesque de personnages héroïques aux
silhouettes aériennes
son travail est tellement admirée par
est clair qu'il devient presque le
sculpteur officiel des nazis d'ailleurs
un journaliste sera renvoyée pour avoir
omis de faire l'éloge de bricker dans un
article sur les jeunes sculpteurs
l'ambassadeur valter hebel le délégué
permanent du ministère des affaires
étrangères se mêle à la conversation
pour expliquer le fonctionnement de sa
nouvelle caméra
arno breker présente sa femme à hitler
sa nationalité étrangère ne pose aucun
problème
et les grecs et selon breaker c'est elle
qui stimule son inspiration de plus pour
hitler la grèce antique était une
civilisation aryenne à berchtesgaden
hitler aime vivre dans une atmosphère
culturel la conversation porte souvent
sur la rule architecture se considère
d'ailleurs comme un artiste hitler se
lance invariablement dans de longs
monologues sur le sujet
en
pour hitler un seul homme est en mesure
de concevoir des bâtiments officiels à
la hauteur du troisième reich
cet homme c'est albert speer que l'on
voit ici sur la droite pendant plusieurs
années je pire à bénéficier de sa propre
maison sur le domaine du berghof qui
comprenait notamment un bureau
d'architectes aux frais du clair une
nouvelle série de plans lui assurait
toujours un accès direct au führer la
première fois que je pire attire
l'attention de hitler c'est lorsque ce
dernier lui confie en 1934 la
réalisation du décor des représentations
du parti la représentation spectaculaire
de 1935 est également le résultat du
travail de cheville puis il devient
rapidement l'architecte officiel de
hitler en charge de concevoir les
bâtiments ostentatoire qu'affectionne
tant le führer en tant que ministre de
l'armement le pire que l'on voit ici à
côté de hitler s'avère être un excellent
organisateur
il va révolutionner la production de
guerre en allemagne au procès de
nuremberg
spir plaide coupable et il est condamné
à 20 ans de réclusion à la prison de
spandau
voici youakim von ribbentrop le ministre
des affaires étrangères de hitler depuis
c'est en retour de son aide pour
l'annexion de l'autriche et l'invasion
de la tchécoslovaquie qu'il obtient un
poste ministériel
il est arrêté en juin 1945 et jugés au
procès de nuremberg ribbentrop prétendre
à n'avoir jamais rien su des
exterminations raciale et des autres
crimes nazis
il sera malgré tout reconnu coupable et
condamné à la pendaison
adolf hitler et ses invités notamment
boorman à sa gauche se mette en route
pour aller visiter le catch stein la
maison de thé du führer qui sera connu
sous le nom du nid d'aigle la
construction du nid d'aigle a été
entreprise par boorman comme cadeau
d'anniversaire pour hitler jusqu'ici
c'est la plus grosse extravagances de
boorman pour la route d'accès il a fallu
mettre en oeuvre de véritables prouesses
techniques
elle fait plus de sept kilomètres de
long et traverse des tunnels creusés
dans la paroi rocheuse
la construction a pris beaucoup de
retard car hitler a interdit
l'utilisation des explosifs le matin le
bruit troubles son sommeil la route
serpente à presque deux kilomètres au
dessus du niveau de la mer et se termine
brusquement devant un portail en cuivre
et en bronze
on accède au sommet cent mètres plus
haut par ascenseur
ce luxueux salons de thé conçu par
norman a coûté 30 millions de reich
marks une véritable fortune à cette
époque en allemagne
ici hitler est en conversation avec l'un
de ses chirurgiens a titré le professeur
karl brandt en 1945
hitler essaiera de faire abattre charles
brandt qui avait organisé la fuite de sa
famille il sera en fait arrêter et pendu
par les américains pour sa participation
aux expérimentations médicales des ss
non
on
la garde personnelle de hitler au
berghof est un détachement ssd troupe de
la ligue standaard
à ses débuts la life stand art est formé
d'une poignée d'hommes appartenant à
l'élite est entraînée par les ss
allemands la sélection de tous les
membres des division ss se fait selon
des critères de pureté raciale et de
stature physique
il étudie leur généalogie jusqu en 1750
en revanche il était impossible de
déterminer avec exactitude l'identité du
grand-père de iter le führer en personne
ne ré donc pas pu y adhérer
le premier commandant de la garde
rapprochée de hitler et joseph sepp
dietrich au cours de la première guerre
mondiale
dietrich était sergent major puis
pendant les années chaotiques de
l'entre-deux-guerres
il a commencé à fortement s'impliquer
dans les groupes parlementaires
d'extrême droite
dietrich est engagée dans les ss en 1928
et il est rapidement devenu sergent
major en 1940 et 1941 dietrich commande
une division du premier corps de blindée
ss en france en grèce et en russie après
le débarquement de 1944
dietrich est à la tête de trois panzer
division du premier corps de blindée ss
dietrich est plus douée pour le
commandement que pour la stratégie pour
beaucoup il est considéré comme un
excellent soldats en 1944 hitler donne à
dietrich le commandement d'une dernière
offensive désespéré à l'ouest au cours
de la bataille des ardennes les assauts
de dietrich ont échoué il sera
finalement battu par les forces
aériennes alliées
après sa défaite dans les ardennes
l'armée de dietrich est envoyé au sud
pour défendre vienne où elle sera
anéantie par l'armée rouge est clair et
furieux il limoge son vieil ami et
leibstadt d'arte est relégué au deuxième
plan
dietrich n'est pas capturé par l'armée
rouge mais il capitule devant l'armée
américaine et leurs livres le reste de
ses unités en mai 1945
la justice américaine va le condamner à
une peine de 25 ans de prison
mais il passera moins de dix ans et
l'uil à sa sortie la justice allemande
le condamne à 18 mois de prison pour son
rôle dans les meurtres des membres de
l'esa au cours de la purge de 1934
cette dietrich est un homme libre quand
il meurt en avril 1966
e
dans les films d'eva braun
on voit très souvent est claire en
compagnie d'enfants il a une préférence
pour o'shea ostermeier la fille de frau
hertz ostermeier la meilleure amie d'eva
braun peut-être ses nombreuses scènes
d'enfants tourné par eva braun
reflètent-elles ses propres espérances
il ne fait aucun doute pour tous ceux
qui la connaissent que la seule ambition
d'eva braun est de devenir une femme au
foyer exemplaires
eva ne s'est jamais réellement intéressé
à la politique après avoir rencontré
hitler pour la première fois elle
demande à hoffman qui à adolf hitler
la gouvernante de l'appartement de
hitler à munich affirmé qu' eva braun
n'était pas très maligne juste une jolie
femme
eva participe rarement aux conversations
sérieuses malgré tout elles fait bonne
figure aux réceptions donné par hitler
elle réussi à s'approprier quelques
connaissances en écoutant les longs
discours d'hitler mais ses centres
d'intérêt sont tout autres en dehors de
la photographie eva adorent regarder des
films romantiques faire du sport et
s'occuper d'animaux et l'affectionnent
également la mode et les romans à l'eau
de rose mais son inclination pour la
danse ainsi que son penchant pour
l'alcool et la cigarette ne sont pas du
goût dit claire elle continue malgré
tout à s'adonner à ses plaisirs en
cachette hitler explique son choix pour
cette campagne de manière très franche
grâce à eva j'oublie tout ce qui
encombre mon esprit elle m'apaise
e
gretl brown la sueur des vins et la
future femme de hermann fairline un
officier ss qui sera liquidée par hitler
à côté de gretl adolphe wagner gauleiter
de la bavière
à
e
hoffmann l'employeur symbolique d'eva
braun parle ici avec le médecin
personnel de hitler le professeur brandt
après le déjeuner les invités quittent
le berghof et font une petite marge de
15 minutes pour se rendre à la maison de
thé chaque jour ickler choisi une
personne différente pour marcher avec
lui en tête du cortège les autres
restent derrière à une certaine distance
cette fois ci hitler a choisi albert
speer
la compétition est féroce d'un entourage
d'hitler pour obtenir l'immense
privilège d'une conversation privée avec
le guide à droite contre le mur et on
peut voir guerdat la femme de martin
bormann et la jeune femme qui encourage
l'actrice magda schnyder à s'approcher
de hitler et marion schooneman une amie
viennoise d'eva braun mario chan est une
des nombreuses actrices être invité au
berghof par martin bormann il invitait
presque toutes les actrices
le docteur joseph goebbels chef de la
propagande du parti nazi ministre de
l'information arrive au berghof
l'ascension de goebbels au sein du parti
a été prodigieuse depuis 1933
il a la mainmise sur les arts la
littérature la musique et l'information
c'est goebel ce alors qu'il était maire
de berlin qui instaurait le salut nazi
en tant que ça lui officielle entre les
membres du parti son dévouement est
clair ne faiblira jamais après la mort
du führer goebel c'est sa femme magda
fonds empoisonné leurs enfants avant de
demander à des soldats et cessent de
leur donner la mort
m
hitler est ici avec le capitaine de la
luftwaffe nicholas von bülow vilain
buchner son assistant personnel qui
porte ici l'uniforme du parti est
également à l'image
hitler en discussions privées avec le
général gerhard siegel
et
arrivé de von ribbentrop ministre des
affaires étrangères
à gauche de l'écran
heinrich himmler chef des ss à côté de
lui reinhardt heydrich chef de la
sécurité du reich heydrich qui a mis en
place les camps d'extermination sera
assassiné à prague en mai 1942 en 1945
himmler se suicidera en absorbant du
poison après avoir été arrêté par la
police militaire britannique
à
ici gretel brown avec l'ambassadeur
valletais révèle grâce au maillage de
gretl avec hermann fait golan en 1944
eva braun obtient une liberté dont elle
a toujours été privé en effet elle peut
maintenant approché le führer en tant
que belle soeur de son officier de
liaison
ainsi eva est désormais autorisé à
apparaître publiquement en compagnie du
chancelier à berlin la liberté retrouvée
d'eva sera de courte durée quand sa
soeur se marient le troisième reich est
à moins d'un an de cette destruction
totale
en 1944
même le berghof pourtant très isolée a
été équipée d'un grand complexe d'abris
anti aériens et tout un réseau de
tunnels et de pièces a été construit
pour éclairer ses proches
un deuxième abri de plus de 300 mètres
carrés est construit pour la famille et
les collaborateurs de martin bormann
les abris du berghof sont enterrés
profondément dans l'aube heure salsberg
protégé par plus de cinquante mètres de
rochers mais les installations sont loin
d'être rudimentaire les abris sont
équipées de l'eau courante et de l'air
conditionné
il y à des carreaux en marbre des sol en
parquet et des mitrailleuses pour garder
les entrées si on avait signalé la
proche des avions alliés toute la vallée
aurait été immédiatement camouflé dans
un brouillard artificiel
en fait les bâtiments du berghof
subiront les attaques alliées 14 jours
seulement avant la fin de la guerre ils
seront alors presque totalement rayés de
la carte
mais hitler et eva ne sont pas dans
l'enceinte du berghof ils sont tous les
deux dans le bunker du führer dans la
ville assiégée de berlin
au printemps 1945
hitler ordonne à eva braun de retourner
au berghof et les sens et préparer le
retour du führer et de son entourage
au cas où il déciderait de mener ses
opérations depuis son refuge
mais evans absolument pas l'intention de
bouger
nombreux sont ceux qui ont fui berlin
mais elle est revenue à la chancellerie
eva ne quittera plus jamais hitler
hitler garde encore l'espoir de voir
berlin secourus mais le 28 avril il est
devenu évident que cette armée fantôme
qui est censée intervenir existe
uniquement dans son imagination
c'est en écoutant radio stockholm que
hitler reçoit le coup de grâce
il apprend que heinrich himmler négocié
la capitulation avec les alliés pour
hitler ceci représente la crise
ultime il est dorénavant évident qu'il
n'y a plus aucun espoir
les derniers aux représentants du parti
nazi dans le bunker de la chancellerie
sont hitler bormann et goebbels les
charrues sont maintenant à quelques
mètres seulement
le bâtiment au dessus du bunker est en
ruine
c'est dans la nuit du 28 avril que
hitler décide finalement d'accéder au
souhait le plus cher d'eva braun qui est
de devenir sa femme le 29 avril entre 1h
et 3h du matin un fonctionnaire de la
mairie célèbre le mariage de adolf
hitler et de eva braun comme prévu par
la loi nazis
le couple jurent qu'ils sont tous les
deux de complète descendance aryenne en
signant le registre de mariage eva
commence à écrire son nom de jeune fille
puis elle s'arrête biffle b est écrit
eva hitler
les témoins sont goebbels et boorman
un petit déjeuner au champagne est servi
après la cérémonie et vannes ira à l'un
des serveurs
vous pouvez maintenant m'appeler fera ou
hitler
hitler a déjà rédigé son testament il a
écrit ma femme et moi avons décidé de
mourir afin d'échapper à la honte d'un
renversement ou d'une capitulation
nous souhaitons que nos corps soit
immédiatement incinérés
le 30 avril à 15h30
hitler et eva se retire dans leur
appartement eva braun absorbe du poison
hitler se tire une balle leur corps ne
seront jamais retrouvés